يعني الخلافات الامريكيه الاسرائيليه لم
تعد بين البيت الابيض وحكومه نتنياهو
هنالك حراك داخل مجلس النواب داخل مجلس
الشيوخ الى اي مدى يمثل ذلك عامل ضغط على
هذه الاداره للتحرك من الاقوال الى
الافعال الامر يت حسنوا رويده رويده نحن
بحاجه الى 60 عضو مجلس شيوخ لكي يتم اي
شيء على مستوى الكونغرس الامريكي ونتحدث
عن تقريبا 16 شخصا اتخذوا موقفا داعما
للقانون الدولي وبذلك نحن بحاجه الى حوالي
30 عضو اخر للضغط بشكل حقيقي على اداره
بايدن للتوقف عن امداد اسرائيل بالاسلحه
من د من دون شروط ولكن هذا تحسن نحن نعرف
مدى قوه اللوبي الاسرائيلي في واشنطن
ولسنوات ما كنا نجد اي عضو في مجلس الشيوخ
او مجلس النواب يتحدث ضد اسرائيل الان
لدينا امريكيون من اصل فلسطيني وم
المسلمين يتحدثون الداخل الكونجرس
بالاضافه الى انتقادات مباشره لاسرائيل
والضغط على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ونحن بحاجه الى ارقام متزايده طبعا لربما
هذا لن يكون بالسرعه المطلوبه لايقاف
الحرب بل يجب ان يقول بايدن للاسرائيليين
انه يتعين عليهم ان يوقفوا هذه الحرب ولكن
نتحدث هنا عن ضغط على مستوى مجلس الشيوخ
وهذا يعزز الجهود الايله الى انتقاد جهود
الحرب الاسرائيليه والدعم جهود الاداره
لوقف هذا النزاع يعني ونحن نتحدث الان سيد
لورنس هنالك تصريحات للرئيس الامريكي
نقلتها رويترز يقول فيها ان نتنياهو لا
يعارض حل الدوله وان وانه ناقش هذا الامر
مع الرئيس مع نتنياهو وقال ايضا بايدن في
هذه الاخبار العاجله من رويترز ان هناك
عددا من انماط حل الدولتين فبعض الدول
الاعضاء في الامم المتحده ليس لديها جيوش
لكن هو يقول بشكل ما انه نتنياهو لا يعارض
حل
الدولتين يعني ما الاساس الذي يستند اليه
ونتنياهو قال منذ البدايه يعني منذ ان كان
سياسيا صغيرا انه لا يؤمن بحل الدولتين هل
تغير موقف نتنياهو
مثلا قليلا نعم تغير قليلا يمكننا ان نفكر
بذلك بالشكل التالي منذ سنتين قالت اداره
بايدن من دون تنفيذ هذه السياسات تقول ان
الحياه الفلسطينيه تعادل الحياه
الاسرائيليه ويحق للشعب الفلسطيني ان
يزدهر ويعيش بكرامه شانه شان الشعب
الاسرائيلي طبعا ما حصل في الاشهر الثلاثه
الماضيه اثبت ان هذه المعادله لم تؤت كلها
ولكن هذا هو هدف الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بعد السابع من اكتوبر عندما
بدات الولايات المتحده تشدد الضوء على
ضروره ارساء الدوله الفلسطينيه
الاسرائيليون كانوا يقولون لا لا لا اذا
ما عينا المواقف الامريكيه على لسان بايدن
او بلينكن كانوا يقولون انتم بحاجه الى
اعطاء الفلسطينيين كل الحقوق وال را
الانسانيه اذا ما لم تكنوا تريدوا الدوله
ما هي الصيغه الاخرى ما من اجابه من الطرف
الاخر وهذا يعود بنا الى حل الدولتين وهذا
ما تفضله الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وه
نسال عن عن مفهوم الولايات المتحده لحل
الدولتين لانه واضح انه اقترب كثيرا مما
يطرحه نتنياهو نتنياهو طرح منذ
البدايه حلا دوله ككوس يكا على سبيل
المثال لا تسيطر على حدودها هذا ما قاله
لا تسيطر على حدودها ليست يمكن يكون لها
عمله وعلم فقط من من علامات الدول يكون
لها عمله وعلم لكن لا تسيطر لا على جوها
ولا على بحرها ولا على حدودها هل هل هذه
هي الرؤيه الامريكيه الان وفق هذه
التصريحات للرئيس
الامريكي لا اعتقد ان هذه التصريحات تشدد
على تفاصيل لقد ينت انواع او انماط مختلفه
من حل الدولتين هناك صيغ مختلفه ولذلك
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تقول اذا ما
لم يكن الهدف الدوله بحد ذاتها الهدف هو
حل ما يعطي الفلسطينيين الحقوق كامله
والقدره على تحقيق الفرص الاقتصاديه كامله
والكرامه الانسانيه اي شيء يؤدي الى تحقيق
هذا الهدف وتامين امن اسرائيل بالنسبه الى
الامريكيين هو جيد لم نغص في التفاصيل بعد
ولكن اعود الى النقطه التي كنت اود ان
انهيها لذلك عمل مع مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بالنسبه الى تطبيع العلاقات
عندما قال نتنياهو نعم انا ضد الدوله انا
ضد الدوله الان ولكن لربما ليس في
المستقبل لربما هذا هو السياق الذي تقول
فيه الولايه المتحده الامريكيه اذا ما
حسنا العلاقه بين اسرائيل والجيران اذا ما
اردنا تحسين العلاقه نحن بحاجه الى دوله
فلسطينيه